the MGM slate is going to be out this
week I'm told by
sources will Stargate be on it please
welcome to Sid check you SFI TV and MO
[Music]
channel I am going to speak up so I'm
sorry if I'm shouting but I'm wor you're
not going be a to hear me over the wind
and the uh waves but look at that how
beautiful is that I don't know what that
box is big big rock anyway so the MGM
plus slate for development goes out I'm
being told actually in the next two
weeks last year this came out on the
10th of January it's a little bit later
this year we actually do already know
some of the projects that are going to
be on that
slate but we don't know a few and
actually Mike Wright the head of MGM
Plus Us in an interview not long ago did
tease that they are planning something
big from the MGM back catalog but he
then laughed and told us he couldn't
tell us what that was just yet now we
know being regular side trackers that
MGM plus is desperate for Stargate it
really sees that
franchise as the Cornerstone for MGM
Plus's growth that if Amazon really want
GM plus to become a major part of prime
that they will need Stargate they need
that TV show that everyone knows the
name of and that sci-fi fans will come
looking for now all of the streaming
services want shows like that Paramount
have Star Trek Disney have Star Wars all
of the streaming platforms need these 10
Poole projects something that they can
build around and for MGM plus that is
Stargate so one of the chances this is
actually going to be on their slate this
year the problem is I'm not sure now as
you guys know I've always been able to
keep pretty much ahead of what's going
on at MGM and Amazon but on this one the
doors kind of locked at the end of
summer autumn when the strikes went back
a lot of the people I speak to one's
actually been made redundant but a lot
of people I speak to have not heard
anything why is that well I think it's
because a decision's been made and what
I've been told before is there's always
going to be a bit of a silence between
decision made and decision
announced and they're pretty good at
that over Amazon they're pretty good at
locking the doors and keeping
stum so when things actually go into
production we will hear Whispers And we
will hear news but when we're in that
bit between unless my source over at
marketing here something I really really
don't think we're going to hear anything
until the announcement happens but
that's fine what are the chances I would
say it's about 50/50 MGM we know in
August last year argued with Amazon to
say look I know you guys want to do a
movie but we want to do a bloody series
come on give us the series it's way more
likely to be successful we have a
business model we have a strategy that
works we have all this demographic
information which supports that actually
the fans us Gators want a TV series and
we don't necessarily want a movie we
want a series that's going to be on our
screens reasonably quickly we want Brad
Wright to be involved in that or at
least somebody else from the Stargate
Hall of Fame Robert Cooper or somebody
but preferably Brad right and we want
this to happen now we are bored of
waiting it's been 13 years now give us
Stargate so top Executives over at MGM
made that argument I know that that
discussion happened I actually got to
see some of the slides and things that
were used to um present this information
so I know the type of information they
were using to make the argument the
problem is I don't know what the
decision was because my source was then
not involved in everything that happened
following they were involved in the
buildup they weren't involved in the
actual then result it's really cold
absolutely Freez I'm in North Wales at
my Caravan and the winds just died down
so I don't have to shout so much but
it's freezing it's really really cold oh
there's a dog walk if I'm honest I have
to give this a percentage I think it's
about 50/50 if I'm really honest um I
think there is a problem with cinema at
the moment and Amazon know this as much
as anybody that it really is hit and
miss they are also expecting Cinemas in
America America particularly to draw in
about a billion dollars Less in the next
12 months than they did last year that's
a big chunk that's like 10% that they're
expecting to to have you know box office
receipts even less so is it a sensible
time to try and take a big new franchise
to the cinema probably not and MGM plus
has been growing actually pretty well
there has been decent growth there has
been a few new shows on there that
people really like and particularly in
America people have discovered that for
basically
$5 they can get access to lots of really
cool MGM historical projects as well as
new stuff what they need though to take
it to the next level is Stargate now
that is where I am thinking that there's
a logical reason there why they should
announce it in their development slate
this year but will
they I'm being told that Amazon is still
leaning toward towards a movie that
would then be followed by a series in
which case it won't appear on the
development slate this year it'll appear
on the development slate next year and
that is at least slightly
frustrating but all we can hope is that
cooler heads are prevailed and Minds
have changed because we desperately want
this project to happen we want a TV
series and then if it's successful give
us a movie in a couple of years I don't
necessarily need 2 hours of Stargate I
want 10 and then 20 and then
30 give us that and at the end of the
day the only thing that really matters
are the Gators give us what we want and
give us Brad right in charge because
that's what we want and we are the
customer and Amazon if anybody knows
this the customer is always right so
come on let's have a new Stargate
franchise let's have something we can
get really EXC excited about and let's
have it soon I don't want something in
2027 I don't want something in 2026 I'll
give you till 2025 and then I'm going to
start losing my ship all right so guys
get into the comments and tell me what
you think what do you think the chances
of Stargate appearing on the new MGM
slate are I'm giving it 50/50 but what
do you think also let's get into the
argument movie or
series which would you prefer which is
the better way to re Kickstart this
amazing franchise get into the comments
and tell me exactly what you think
because this is a community and that's
what we do baby if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
and you'll never miss any of our new
videos also go over to patreon.com
citrek where most of our new videos do
premere first and you get to see them
without the adverts you lucky bunnies
finally go to c.co do.uk which is our
dedicated website and we do articles
based on most of our videos and we try
to add a little bit more information for
you to digest got you Che that out too
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next
[Music]
time